hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent attacking game to share with
you from 1996
two Dynamic players on board on the
white end Vasily vanchuk and he's up
against vessel into paulov
opening wise it is an open Sicilian
I think this game does a nice job of
reminding us of the weakest Square in
Black's Camp F7 typically this is a
point targeted out of the opening phase
uh in this one it's targeted in an
atypical way in the middle game
alright
night or variation
this is securing the queen post when
she's on C7 she won't be bugged by night
also some prep work for Queen side
expansion eventually
Bishop E2
classical variation and E6 scaveningen
variation
now I'd like to caution those of you who
may be on the black side in this very
position caution you about playing B5
too soon it may seem like this is the
first available moment you could play B5
but do know after B5
white could play Bishop F3 this is a bit
of an irritating move to deal with
you could shut down the possibility of
E5 with
playing E5 yourself there's
problems with that
creating a weakness on D5
but um here's a quick way you could
already lose his black Bishop B7 E5
all right my point here is that there is
an important prep move black should be
playing before black is ready to go
with V5 I'll be highlighting what that
move is soon enough
E6 on board castles Bishop E7 white gets
rolling with a pawn Duo black castles
and white takes some time out to secure
the king get off of the open diagonal
if white tries to press in the center
with E5 while the king is still on G1
black could take advantage of that
after E5 takes takes there's a pin
tonight
you take my knight I take your knight
and say check and then Circle back to
recapture on F6
okay safety first move nine now white is
ready to go with E5
now black stops it
two tasks are being performed by The
Black Queen
this is one
stop E5 and the other is to secure the
bishop once it's on B7
this is the prep move I was speaking of
earlier
Queen C7 now preps the B5 advance
for instance if white plays A3 here B5
could be played no problems
Bishop F3 so what Bishop B7 two
important tasks from C7
okay
A4
this was the first moment black was
ready to play B5 successfully this is
when white cuts it out
Knight C6 Bishop B3
Rook E8 what's happening with Rook E8
opens up a square for the bishop also
prepares to challenge White's Pawn duo
with E5
additionally
this move Rook E8 is leaving F7 a bit
more vulnerable
so there's a progression in the game
in the initial setup
we recognize F7 as the weakest Square
then black castles and F7 is
strengthened there's a rook there
defending it
some moves later the king Rook is
excited about going to some other Square
it is then back to a weakened Square
it's difficult to predict how uh or
anticipate how this is going to be taken
advantage of but I think it's a useful
note you could be making to yourself
weakened strengthened back to weakened
once that King Rook moves
alright from here Bishop F3
Rook B8
G4 each side is ready to go with the
Knight Pawns
in order to scare away
a night
okay from here Bishop f8 G5 Knight D7
Bishop G2
my initial thought with Bishop G2 is
okay you're getting out of the Queen's
way maybe she comes out here that could
show up in some lines or even a rook
pivot on F3 looking for some
kind of caveman
type attack along the H file
I think another note we could be making
about this move is that
we're staying out of reach of a knight
the White's ready to next play F5
possibly and you don't have to worry
about this Knight dropping into E5 with
tempo
okay from here it is Knight takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight
B5 a b a b
newly opened file white hops to it
this is the deepest intersection Square
white has available to him
making use of it Rook on the seventh
rank
and this kicks the queen back home
now
surprisingly enough
the best move here
is to go to B7
and this involves giving up a pun
if Rook B7 white could take advantage of
the pinned Rook
with Knight takes B5
but the computer's saying this is still
a fine position for black
this is a really active Queen
so this is maybe some of the
compensation for black really active
Queen and
uh safer King as well
also how valuable another way to look at
it is how valuable is this Rook if it's
allowed to be maintained on the seventh
rank is it really a five point Rook
anymore
maybe it is worth like six points
okay in any case the queen is kicked
back home
and now a very instructive move here
by ivanchuk
he ends up playing B4
so what is happening with B4 I think you
know this this move B4 it's not
considered the best move
computer saying you could go for some
line here with E5
and then F5
and if Black's trying to kick the way
kick away the Knight now you have some
capture on F6 and then some sacrifice on
D5
okay
the second best move the move played in
the game V4 this is a nice reminder of
you know when we're playing a game what
are we trying to do little by little we
can only make one move one move at a
time of course we're trying to find ways
to slowly improve our position but
there's not always going to be a way we
could you know make a move and it be an
improvement sometimes we need to take
some time out
and secure our well-positioned piece
that's what's Happening Here
an improvement for black if black was on
move right now Improvement for black
would be to inconvenience
a night on C3
some stabilizing move is in order here
for white
B4 onboard this Knight will not be
kicked so fast an additional Point
behind it you do take away a square from
the Knight
now there are a lot of weaknesses as
well white is creating with B4 I should
mention
this is probably the biggest one C4 is
now a whole
and you know getting getting a knight
here someday
okay
there's some pros and cons with this
move it's more so about stabilizing the
Knight right now
from here E5
many weaknesses in the position C4
is weak and White's camp now D5
is weak in Black's camp
why is black playing in this way why is
black giving this Knight access to the
D5 Square well he wants this Knight to
function
E5 is creating a square for the Black
Knight
now there is a move here
that may tempt a lot of players
playing as white right here but
ivanchik was not tempted
by this idea to capture the Knight
in this game the Knight goes to D5
it may be tempting to take this Knight
and then exchange Queens
and then land another Rook on the
seventh rank but this would be a really
rare case
where the white Rooks really aren't
so well positioned surprisingly enough
because
this guy is a reliable Defender
of G7
so it's like a three-point piece is
negating 10 points
black could go on the offensive here
Target the C2 Pawn
so white is not lured into this
optically
uh you know this somewhat appealing
looking uh two Rooks on the seventh rank
variation
Improvement for the Knight Knight D5
from here Bishop G4
Queen D2
and now Knight to C6
so this last move
again draws some attention to the F7
Square it's no longer
as secure
there is a star move now for team white
in this position
I wonder if you can spot it if you'd
like to go ahead pause the video what
move would you play here as white
okay you ready to go
all right the best move is
G6
now I think many of you may have been
thinking about Rook takes Pawn
straight away
this is not working for white because
white does not have any wonderful
discovered check with the bishop
it'd be nice though if the bishop could
get to G5 and say check
this is what the move
G6 is setting up
setting up some idea
of a possible discover check setting up
an idea to strike Black's Queen
okay
in this game Knight takes Rook is played
let's have a look at the two different
ways black can be capturing on G6
if
F takes G6 white could continue with
Bishop G5 and there's a serious problem
here for the black queen
if you move the Knight to E7 there's
this sacrifice on f8 and then you could
pick your favorite way to capture on E7
if you're blocking with the bishop
there can follow Knight takes Bishop
and then black is in this pin and white
is on move and could look to improve the
queen
this is looking really good hitting the
bishop also looking at Queen F7 check
okay what other move might there be here
for black
Queen C8 could be met with Rook C7
if the queen goes here you simply lose
the Knight and if the queen goes here
check this move out
Queen C3 this is a beautiful move
hitting the Knight for a second time
and also threatening a Checkmate in two
with Rook takes bishop and then Queen
takes G7 mate
if black tries to stop it with Knight E5
there's another point with the queen on
C3
you ready
Rook A1 and the queen would be trapped
okay what is the queen
uh what is the White Queen on C3 not
doing
okay that's what could happen if black
captures with the F Pawn if this capture
happens now we could see this Rook takes
F7 move
if King takes rook in this position now
white would get the discovered check
and next win the queen
okay in this game The Rook is captured
Pawn takes Pawn check
King goes to the corner
and now no capture The Rook just yet
first an improvement of the bishop
Bishop G5
if
in this position The Rook blocks okay in
the game first of all the queen goes to
D7 if the Rook blocks
white could take the Rook
and then one of the ways to win is to
Simply promote
while the Bishop is pinned white is
going to be winning the queen
if you're blocking with the bishop right
now okay that's just going to end up
losing a piece you lose the rook and
then the bishop so
in this game what is tried Queen D7
and now a bit of a humorous move here
not sure the point of this one but The
Rook is captured and Chucky promotes to
a knight
or some
psychology going on with that move like
of course if it's a White Queen you know
you're gonna have to take the queen but
I wonder you know did Black have to
think for a little while longer like you
know what could I maybe get away with
not taking the night
in this position
I don't know I'm not sure the details on
this one but
kind of an interesting move to see here
the under promotion to a night either
way whatever it is Black's taking it
Rook takes Knight
from here we have Queen F2 Queen
functioning like a queen
on the file on the diagonal restricting
the queen
from here King G8
what piece is not playing for white
the light Square Bishop
E5 on board
this guy's eyes are now opened up two
interesting squares for the bishop
from here H6 now
if this Pawn is captured
we're basically going to have a similar
follow-up in the game so let's just see
it
H6 on board Knight B6 hitting the queen
and also opening up D5 for the bishop
it's a very very nice finish
Queen C7 Bishop D5 check
ing H7 Bishop E4 check
King G8 Knight D5 look at how beautiful
this is the knight in the bishop
excellent pieces they are now in all of
the white pieces are in attacking
in in an attacking position right here
Queen D7 one move out
and black resigns Can you spot the final
move
feel free to pause the video okay very
nice touch
very nice ending to this one 97
check and black resigns
a great interference move
what are blacks options if the game
continued
if you take with the queen you lose the
queen
if you take with the Rook you lose your
king
and if you take with the bishop
black doesn't control F7 and white could
sneak in there with a check
and then form this battery and there is
no good defense to Queen H7 mate you
have to make silly moves like Bishop
here Queen here
black goes no further throws in the
towel after this flashy
final move Knight to E7
anyhow
Feel Free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section
below I hope you enjoyed it maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye